what's up everybody we just finished
shooting a music video well part of the
music video we are collaborating with
many artists releasing to help promote
the upcoming animated film Addams family
in honor of it we are collaborating with
fellow youtuber Mike Tompkins who is
famous for doing a lot of musical like
beatboxing video and we are gonna be
featured in his video and you guys can
also submit your parts so you can be
part of the snap along so you can check
out the link in the description and
follow the directions so you can be part
of this one big Addams Family snap
belong video and we can be in one
together all right now enjoy the blog
good morning guys
when ozs yeah alright so today is a
beautiful sunny Californians Sunday and
we are about to have breakfast
what is the plan after breakfast so
whammy we're gonna swam kick they really
you look so tan dude cuz you were in
Laughlin with your dad recently how is
it looks fun oh we're in the raft and
surprisingly well like out of all the
people is the strongest you're gonna
strongest like what do you mean the rest
like we'll explain it so there's a few
people on the raft right uh-huh held by
long rope from the jet ski mm-hmm
so I was right here and my cousin was
right here and he's really strong yeah
because I'm so like I got hold on longer
than anybody else so the jet skis
pulling you guys on the water yeah Dane
that sounds dangerous and fun u-turn and
fun that's like that's the perfect combo
for me when they turn like your rap it
was crazy
whoa
go max speed yeah so sometimes like your
arms yet tired you just fall off ah oh
no sir doesn't hurt when you fall in
water later it's your feet cuz like
bouncing off the wall because water is
sixty miles per day that's fast yeah cuz
water gets hard like based off of the
safe you fall into a pool of water from
like five storey building or something
the water turns into like cement pretty
much like the impact once you hit the
water it gets pretty crazy there's
something in there with physics and I
think it's because the water molecules
are pretty thick and like compared to
your buddy you don't know what you're
talking at daddy's recipe book hold on I
got to point something out that was so
cute that I found the other day I got
exposed this is too cute look at this
for one of the recipes he said tip
really liked it see what she thinks
after having the salt and cut what is it
outing Oh cutting fresh ingredients I
can't read your but the fact that it's I
read thank you put tip really liked it
that made me feel so special I know
daddy put him [ __ ] I'm sharing with you
what daddy wrote about me he is an Isaac
also has a similar notebook that you
guys got from Hong Kong right yeah
that's funny but I just thought that was
super cute we're ready to eat
yeah okay we have a very luxurious and
fresh ingredient look at breakfast oh I
bet oh I thought okay you're not fat
you're a brownie boy wait barely dude
you're crazy that puberty wait hi can I
gain a lot of weight through puberty
like I started eating a lot more girls
like pumpkins hungry
and it started eating and eating and
eating and couldn't stop beating a lot
of weight and then but the fun the end
of puberty that I was able to lean out
again your body was able to use up all
that fat oh yeah yeah look at you
growing boy all right so we're going to
the pool aren't we men yes and then
we're both slim filming wait be careful
you're not blocking the light
all right over the mic is yeah sure the
mic hole is closed Isaac near at this so
we haven't all gotten to the pool in a
long time Isaac family so I'm finally
going as a family which means we can
jump in and not do this you know because
it just it already feels good that you
know your breathe thank you oh really
what we should go out sometime
[Music]
yeah well doesn't know anything then
won't hurt him
where's this going
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright guys we're gonna flip and
apparently this camera's waterproof
sorry about her breath this carry water
booster a swig yeah we're Casey just
came back from CVS cuz he got me some
ear drops alright because in my head
right now or in my ears I have I'm
supposed to warm about that so I was in
here saying that you should put it to
body temperature yeah so like I'm doing
my hair and I'll and then I'm just like
you can hear the actual like the water
stuck in your ears or Chinese it's like
if you just tap it it sounds like so
earlier I was like jumping up and down
like and doing this with like trying to
get the water out of my ear and I was
successful with my right ear with my
left viateur no matter what I do I can't
get it out and that's actually what
started Isaac's ear infection last time
and I'm not trying to get an ear
infection very true so thank you for
getting me the ear drops it will dry up
the water in my ear on the way there I
was like Isaac we got to stop swimming
our family keeps getting your infections
or like your problems right now I know
and that's why you got some ear plugs
with you that was Isaac's idea to
actually go kind of
that I actually kind of got a hurry
don't watch my say Harvey Harvey hurry
and then um I'm excited for you yeah
what huh go to a party all right I do
mention video buddy I'm going to a party
and but before the party Nicki and I are
gonna go shopping because there's some
good sales going on and I'm gonna finish
getting ready at her house for Gina's
birthday party but she's calling it the
funeral for her 20s because she just
turned 30 and so it's all funeral themed
I've got some lace gloves and then I
have this thing too there we go
well it's kind of ruined cuz I like it
here I'm gonna be wearing this dress
very funeral leather jacket in case it's
cold but I highly doubt it because it's
freaking hot but I always like to be
prepared so true so ironic that we're
promoting Adams family and like in then
you go to a funeral party movie but it's
pretty dang fitting how the timing
worked out where they were like hey you
want to be a part of this project not
like yeah it's perfect to include it oh
my goodness look at the cats okay where
is Maya's face she is under his neck
that's so cute
oh hey Pete why not when he went to go
get me that your jobs get your jobs are
like a dark theme happy birthday but I
which is perfect for Gina's present and
I you're saying like who actually buys
the happy birthday bag with no
excitement on there's no exclamation
mark there's no something's there's no
color there's yeah
no happiness ugly in the word how did
you read it and you when you say yeah
those like yeah it's something happy
birthday like this perfect 40th present
sue says tiff is gonna go to the
birthday party me and I think we're
gonna have a blast playing some video
games now we're gonna have a boys night
another one yeah keep on having boys
night that's summertime he's got her
party to go to
we got some video games to play it's a
movies to watch and some junk food to
eat I may be good I love you Mike hmm
I'm gonna take you guys I ask switching
over POVs look who's here are you push
the thing or she doesn't on open the
door
this is funny I had it made you had to
push one of the ends and then the handle
comes out with this future collar cool
never been in here ready to go shopping
both yes you ready to get all the deals
yes a deal I did it's a sane
we're ready to get the deals let's do it
[Music]
shopping open the door girl alright so
now we're heading back to Nicki's and
going to Jesus going to if you're going
to a party gonna eat all the alcohol
alright guys look at us
we're so ready just kiss Gina's xx
goodbye I love your lipstick look how
good you look
oh yay and then side note Nikki did
mommy yeah it looks so freakin good
she did the eyeshadow and the she helped
me with the eyeliner like with this look
it looks really good oh my goodness and
then other side note the party
supposedly started two hours ago so
we're really bleep but it's very good
reason man look how good we look I mean
this takes time and you're gonna do a
themed party you better expect some late
guests and it's funny because she did
because originally with eight o'clock
yeah she moved it up you guys are very
late and it's now nine ten but then I
took that note to be like okay it's a
real part-time date yeah pretty much
but we're still an hour late for that
yeah leaving now okay yeah it's bye week
this took time this look you look great
we lose doesn't doesn't happen okay
now look at Nikki's full getup look at
that headband Oh No look at how handsome
Steve look look at oh wow I'm thoroughly
impressed man
you look great you both look so good
she's mean you guys look awesome and
their side thank you very very sad yeah
my dear Casey stuck at home I know he's
being a good teddy I know that's a good
that's a good dad work a good dad goals
I know and I'll make sure the party
extra hard I'll actually double party
tonight for Casey that's for you buzz oh
yeah I know what would you be drinking
for anything
uh probably Moscow Moscow mules or gin
and tonic I'm gonna do also in Moscow
Mia they don't do it gentieman see Casey
why do you hear that baby you're such a
good friend what a great friend
party time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
flowers covers just another one this is
when we try it again yeah look at that
now that is a shots of frame and look at
these cuties see the funeral party
experience I really
[Music]
No
where is it where's my card whoa all
right myself but you did that oh my god
that was creepy do it again
[Music]
[Music]